you got oh we're good we're good
lights going hey guys Ryan the right
Here I am here with my two first cousins
who I never really see I'm in New Jersey
right now
this one's Christopher pool team pool
leg up on nine book yes he's a teacher
but teaches four beautiful causes
autistic people okay yes I forgot
exactly what it was again I'm sorry I
always wanted to get good at pool and
since they're here and my cousin's not
pool team I thought it would be fun to
learn together on how to be a cool
player because let's face it they're the
ones who probably get the most [ __ ] out
there am i right you're good at pool
you're hot that is baby come on yeah you
you know anytime I make a shot if I like
make like three in a row you're like
it's pretty hot right yeah you sound
uncertain let's play the games begin
lets us play a game of the poor but
Christopher this line is that line I
know and I get to choose whatever balls
like striper solid right cool cool we
didn't you just need to know I both have
a stripe in softball don't know how it
turned out that way genetic disorder
runs in the family right guys hi I'm
justice stripes just strike just
straight
okay yeah I bet that's a pool thing
right yeah I know what that's like
yeah too much go for the ten ball
described on him you got to learn how to
control your strength if there's one
thing I'm going to tell you that was
solicitude on miscues miscues was habits
even if the ball Center didn't hit the
ball center shut off so to hit cue is to
be sent dude okay
god I am censored live life here we go
stripes which everyone's the easiest I
can choose maybe just find one I don't
want to go too easy I don't want to make
the game any advice here Chris
is this gonna say if you want to go for
anything you want to draw back on that
ball you want to shoot him the bomb the
cue ball right above Center it right
below Center and follow through with
your shot and you'll pull back come off
this route for the side Wow he's
probably very calculated
it runs in the family
baby I'm not gonna be filming this for
like more than a few more minutes
very good is it not good that it stayed
where it did you know how are you saying
oh the purple ball my bad little right
deep do you know which one the key was I
know what the cue ball is the white one
right here ah no I am I got scared and
intimidated like the first time we made
love I'm sorry so technical so technical
I don't know I feel like Neil Young
Betty's not an emotional enough you know
I don't see the emotion at I'm really
judging Chris on this there's he's very
technical but he lacks emotion for the
game for example I'm the one people are
gonna root for cuz I am emotional about
this game I am passionate lucky shot
attract you hard to impress yourself
impress himself yes yes the purple ball
comes again to the challenge table what
must be
nice shot Christopher Wow
the game this is important much more to
being over oh dude - you know what you
do too much you didn't do it right okay
too much power your number one complaint
baby your number one complaint it's from
you know I do you ever scared oh my gosh
too much too much too much is the word
I mean it's are we going on eight
minutes and 40 seconds how long you want
this video to be
that really made me feel good fool
he hit my fallin damn scratch what an
embarrassment I can't believe it plays
on a team does it feel good yeah it's
like the first time it's not you know
where it's going two balls one hole I
don't know how they got it done but
amazing there we go this is like when
Rocky changed the Soviet you son of a
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
beautiful let's say beautifully maybe
the games almost okay you know what I
think this needs to be an epic game and
I honestly think before lets me save for
last because that ball is my number one
enemy it's like you know when you go
through a lot of bosses and video games
then you get to that ultimate boss
purple ball
here we come baby just hit the damn ball
just hit the damn ball you should talk
with me more respect I have earned my
respect
Oh
purple ball now how do I win the game I
call this pocket no that's a no that's a
close game going up against the pro
thank you guys
Thank You Veronica for using the camera
there yeah I'm actually a little bit
turned on right now
thank you because I lost thank you Jeff
thanks for letting me use this place and
Tyrone Magnus thanks for visiting me a
beautiful black man you yeah I flew
thousands of miles to see you Tyrone
when you clearly make more money than me
and you didn't fly to see me but I guess
that's how it works right I got a show
here gonna show my value invest because
I love you Tyrone love you